ça peut sembler étonnant mais les
graines de citrouille qu'on trouve dans
les collations santé les céréales ne
sont pas produites ici au canada
pourtant la culture des citrouilles pour
les graines a un énorme potentiel tant
sur le plan commercial cas gros nomique
quelques rares agriculteurs ont décidé
de se lancer dans l'aventuré
début octobre la météo est favorable et
la journée s'annonce chargée pour
sébastien angers il a juste la
récolteuse monté sur son tracteur une
étrange machine avec sa roue et ses
grands pics hérissé
[Musique]
dans le champ des citrouilles bien mûrs
sont alignés en rang producteurs bio
porcin maraîchers et de grandes cultures
sébacées angers expérimente cette
culture depuis deux ans il a 12 hectares
a récolté jeu confiait n'avoir 400 kg de
temps on
parce que pour une deuxième année là je
suis vraiment satisfait
au volant de son tracteur ils avancent
lentement la roue à l'arrière en film et
citrouilles une à une sur les pointes
puis les cucurbitacées sont dirigés vers
un broyeur qui les écrase un tambour
sépare ensuite la chair et les graines
c'est pour les graines justement que ces
basses et angers fait pousser des
citrouilles
la graine retrouve bel avait jusqu'à
présent
encore des risques du pain manque et
tout savoir sans enlever à de l'autre
étape de notre voyage la culture des
cucurbitacées pour le marché frais et la
transformation est populaire c'est la
sixième production légumière en
importance au pays elle atteignait plus
de 130 mille tonnes métriques
commercialisé en 2010 est le coeur de la
production provient du québec et la
moitié des cucurbitacées cultivés dans
la province sont des citrouilles mais
elles sont différentes de la variété
cultivée pour les graines à ouvrir ce
trou d'alwyn
la russie ont vraiment la différence des
grands l'enveloppé de vias faut vraiment
la curée pour vraiment avoir la tête en
france venu à la barre
ces graines de citrouilles sont moins
coriace et elles ont une forte teneur en
protéines elles sont utilisées dans les
collations santé en garniture dans les
salades et on en fait aussi de l'huile
la grande majorité de celles qui sont
vendues sur le marché viennent de très
loin autriche europe de l'est chine et
inde entre autres
ces basses et angers a eu l'idée d'en
produire localement il a fait ses
premiers essais au printemps 2020 son
entreprise agricole était alors fragile
sur le plan financier le jeu 50 hectares
tout le monde pense qu'il faut brosser
pour une fille
moi j'ai dû au fait y voir à petit que
je veux faire les choses différemment
que je pense que voir réussir à faire
mieux avec moins adepte de l'agriculture
régénérative qui vise à restaurer les
sols et chercher à diversifier ses
cultures à intégrer une nouvelle famille
de plantes plutôt lente a dû verser au
total plus de demandes par résilience
une voûte à santos heures puis par
conséquent la santé de ton sol te donne
lui rappelle tenir
pour résilient doit-on entreprises
agricoles de plus les résidus de
citrouilles que la récolteuse laisse
derrière fertilise le seul
set charlebois se décomposer l'année
prochaine et servir en guinée mais de
fertilisants pour la culture sur chacun
sa 200 grammes par par citrouille piano
laden
après une année en solo sébacées angers
a convaincu 3 autres producteurs de se
lancer dans l'aventuré des graines de
citrouille avec lui dont thomas vinet un
producteur biologique de l'est ontarien
ça me tue
les cucurbitacées n'ont pas encore
atteint le stade de mûrissement idéal
mais c'est prometteur avec une machine
spécialisée sébacées angèle et met en
andains en prévision de la récolte en
faisant rouler lestrohan détache le
pédoncule la citrouille ont les mains en
remportant à faciliter le processus de
l'école
si on laissait environ les citrouilles
dans un an des environs une période de 5
à dijon pour la cité des citrons qui
sont promus occupent ils ont manqué de
soleil en août est bon ça va emmener
faire les fameux rire et rendre les
irène beaucoup plus uniforme des mots de
la qualité que nous vous la récole au
total les quatre producteurs de graines
de citrouille situés dans quatre régions
différentes compte 30 hectares en
culture en régie biologique et
conventionnelle
l'an prochain les superficies vont
tripler
l'idée c'est de travailler en équipe
avec les agriculteurs qu'est ce que je
leur donne des contres production et e
et s'occupe de la production de rendre
la citrouille à ce stade ci et puis moi
je m'occupe la portion récolte là le
réputé conditionnement et de la mise en
marché c'est à dire que plus on partage
leur auto à une tête en fonction du
risque était
kaki prix
l'important est actuellement brive
respire
chacun tire un intérêt là d'un dans le
bien commun tout le monde
on est peut-être quatre producteurs dans
le projet puis
c'est bah si nous nous amène à bompas
un fabricant québécois de collations
santé s'est engagé à acheter toute la
récolte la demande est particulièrement
forte dans le secteur de l'alimentation
biologique en ordonnant jusque-là
protéines végétales est en croissance
le marché veut également la
transformation des protéines végétales
est en cours on peut vraiment jouer en
augmentation
et après deux ans d'apprentissage et des
ses erreurs ses basses et angers est
convaincu de l'énorme potentiel de cette
culture au québec
[Musique]
moi c'est ma foi mais c'est marc grenier
à 60 ans en arrière
je goûte pas de quoi puisque
d'aboutissement d'action que j'ai du
plaisir et en actions